hello everyone and welcome to an awesome
game of chess from yesterday's champion
showdown uh from round two it is gary
caspar versus hikaru nakamura and uh as
you know kasparov comes out pretty much
once a year to to play chess in saint
louis and uh he doesn't uh
uh some okay last year i believe in
zagreb he he did play uh in the indie
regular event where he had uh brush up
on on chess theory but here as it's
chess 960 or chess 90x or official
random however you want to call it to i
i don't want to call it just a nine legs
but if you guys i insist uh you can do
that you know in the comfort of your own
home uh but yeah uh here he can just uh
come prepare a little bit and then uh
just play regular chess of course he is
still quite the beast and uh uh he he
will of course try to do very well this
year last year like i said uh he he had
like five out of ten i don't know if he
was like on 50 but he it was a fairly
good result and he said that as long as
he doesn't just get obliterated in an
event he should be coming back every
year but he's already 59 years old he
car is 34 so it's quite quite the
difference so let's see how gary deals
with the speed demon
in this wild position so you can see the
for those of you who are maybe new to
this the pieces are not regularly placed
this is just 960 as there are 960
different formations that the board can
take and this is obviously one of them
they are selected at random and the
position that is selected that is being
played on all the boards so kasparov has
the white pieces and he opens with g4
which is very interesting as if you put
the uh starting position to an engine
the engine will give you d4 as best c3
is best uh b3 is best g3 is best but not
g4 g4 uh is something uh uh uh gary uh
came up with as i believe the players
are allowed to study the position that
will be played for like an hour before
the tournament starts so they can
prepare at least a little bit because
they've never actually seen this
position so already as of move one uh we
have a completely new game and uh if are
interested in the time format this is
rapid chess 20 minutes per player and
you get a five second increment starting
from move one the price fund is 150 000
plus uh
not plus and the first place is uh 37
and uh fifty thousand dollars so
adjust some uh extra info for you guys
to
wield with
uh so yeah kasparov opens with the g4
and it of course makes uh very good
sense there's already a rogue behind the
pawn the queen is now uh open on this uh
wonderful diagonal so hikaru plays c6
already countering the the white queen
on h1 we have c4 by kasparov and now
pawn to g5 hikaru also does the same
opens up the rook and the the queen and
now h4 uh uh uh
gary wants to play h captures on g5 and
open up the white queen so he got
replaced g characters and h4 queen
captures and now pawn to d5 striking in
the center c capture c captures and not
knight to c3 uh kasparov goes after the
d5 pawn and now you could advance it to
d4 but as kasparov um i chose this wild
g4 line obviously he has something maybe
even prepared for this uh he car the uh
sort of a sort of timid e6 move uh with
e3 by kasparov uh we have knights to g6
just nicely continuing development with
tempo the queen is attacked queen to h5
and now knight to c6 by hikaru and here
kasparov plays g5 it's a beautiful move
uh takes control of f6 and h6 and this
knight is now coming to h2 to g4 and
then to f6 if this knight lands on f6
then it should be very very good for
kasparov so bishop to d7 hikaru has to
move the bishops in order to castle uh
we have pawn to d4 and now pawn to a6
knight to h2 kasparov starts the the
knights journey uh bishop the d6 and
knight the g for preparing knight to f6
check and now of course the bishop to e7
hikaru now controls the f6 square and
now we have bishop to d2 if you go some
like knight h6 attack the rook just rook
a fate and it's not really all that much
uh kasparov really wants the knight on
f6 to put pressure on the h7 pawn as
well as the as the center of the board
so bishop to d2 uh we have castles queen
side castles by hikaru and now rook to
h1 you can see that the bishop here the
queen and the rook are all nicely
attacking that h7 pawn also once the
knight lands on f6 uh it's not gonna be
easy uh holding this so rook the g7
hikaru adds another defender a3 by
kasparov and now king to b8 we have
bishop to c2 and now preparing to bring
the rook into the game and now knight to
f6
uh sorry e5 uh
attacking in the center and only now
kasparov jumps with knight to f6 we have
bishop to e6
you could also trade right away for
example bishop characters g captures and
rogue g to g8 but then it's um
well it's a it's uh it's a question of
uh how do you play this because uh the
h7 point is saying the d5 phone is
hanging
but it's not all that clear once he
captures on d4 the white king is in the
center and you know hikaru is pretty
good at positions like these so uh uh
although it is possible uh hikaru
instead goes bishop to e6 uh we have
knight to e2 by kasparov now adding more
defense to the d4 pawn bishop to c3 is
coming
rook to c8 and now bishop to c3 and now
pawn to e4 hikaru closes the center now
also uh sort of limits the the mobility
of the light square bishop but he'll of
course allows pawn to f3
um kasparov has many options here he
could also just play bishop characters
on e4 for example captures and d5 is
also possible
but f3 is uh
maybe more more precise so he captures
an f3 queen captures on f3 and now queen
back to d8
uh now saying okay if you if you put the
pressure on the h7 pawn or if you
capture it at some point i will capture
on g5 so knights to g3 kasparov just uh
continues improving his position bishop
captures an f6 queen captures on f6
offering a queen trade and this would be
good for him for example if hikaru
trades queen captures g captures rook g
the g8 um the h7 pawn again is is
hanging the the bishops are are very
very strong uh the pawn on f6 is very
strong it's very hard to to reach it uh
once this knight lands for example on e5
it's going to be a beautiful beautiful
position so yeah he should be very very
close to winning here so instead queen
to c7 by hikaru and now uh hikaru says
okay you capture my rook i'm going to
capture your knight here but
it's not possible if if queen captures
on g3 checking e2 just queen g2 check
and now if you don't want to go back and
lose the rook you have to play something
like king to d3 so the rook defends the
rook but then bishop f5 check and you
are in a mating net just the e4 knight
to f4 with check king the e3 and now we
need to check you give you give up a
knight captures queen f2 that will be
checkmate as all of the squares now are
covered so uh after this queen to c7
move kasparov boldly goes forward king
to f2 defends his knight so the rook is
still hanging rook g the g8 and now rook
captures on h7 finally and now kasparov
is just up upon and hikaru will have to
fight for for equality so knight to a f8
we have rook to h6 now and king to a8
still the dark square bishop is in the
game so it makes sense to move the king
away from this diagonal and well
generally as far away from the action as
possible rook to g1 kasparov brings the
rook into the game and now knight to a5
preparing to bring the knight to c4
we have knights to e2 and now knight to
c4 we have bishop to d3 you don't want
the bishop here as it's undefended so
just bishop to d3 and now queen to d7
uh we have rook g to h1 and now
preparing rook to h8 as kasparov is up
upon uh he wants to trade off both pairs
of rooks and then just enjoy his his
advantage so knights the g6 and now
knights the f4 if he can trade off the
knight as well that's uh going to take
him even closer to his to his goal so
hikaru trades uh he doesn't find
anything else captures captures knight
to d6 and now just rook to h8 now caspar
will trade off both pairs of rooks 94
check you have to trade here as uh
there's a royal fork currently happening
so bishop captures e captures uh d
captures on e4 and now rook captures on
g8 we have rook capture sanjit and just
a rook to h8 so uh cleaning everything
off the board we have rook captures and
h8 queen captures an h8 and now what do
you play uh king the a7 must be played
if you try to trade off the queens
because it's bishops of opposite colors
uh
well
you can just trade and then king e3 you
attack the pawn for example bishop here
just d5 and then you march your king
into the game and of course very easily
win the game so it's not possible as the
black king is too far away so instead of
king to a7 by hikaru queen to e5 now
very strong and very very good move by
by gary just uh centralizing the queen
the queen will be most powerful and on
such a such a great square uh bishop to
d5 by hikaru and now pawn the f5 now the
pawn is are incredibly strong at some
point g6 will be played and then uh
kasparov will either have a past g pawn
or a past f pawn so here pawn to b6 with
a4 and ponte a5 we have king to e3
getting the king into the action as well
bishop to b7 and now pawn to b3 putting
the pawn on a light square if your
opponent has a light square bishop
usually isn't the greatest of ideas but
here kasparov has a very very concise
idea because if let's say queen d5 you
can just trade and yes your pawn is
hanging but kasparov will just push it
to b4 and if captures captures if you
attack this spawn again he will just
push it to a5 so it's it's not a problem
so here queen to d8 by hikaru are going
after the g5 pawn and now just pawn to
f6 and now kasparov once he pushes g6
he's threatening g7 and also if capture
is just f7 you already have a pass pawn
on f7 so queen to c8
and now uh pawn to d5 here the bishop is
hanging so you have to be careful not to
blunder a piece it would be terrible to
lose this game by blundering a piece
uh and now pawn to d5 the queen defends
the bishop and also the pawn starts
marching forward we have queen to g4 by
hikaru and bishop to d4 now we have
queen to f3 with check king to d2 now
comes queen to d3 with check and king to
e1 and now how do you continue checking
the white king we have queen to be one
check king to f2 and now uh how do you
play this you should continue with
something like queen to c to check or
queen to a to check or queen captures on
b3 uh hikaru goes for queen captures and
b3 he can always just continue checking
the the king and kasparov just pushes
the pawn there's nothing for him to do
but this so d6 uh queen to c2 with check
with king to g3 and now hikaru should
play something like queen d3 or queen b3
check but he plays d3 and it makes sense
he opens up this diagonal he wants to
play queen to g2 check so if kasparov
wastes a move capturing this uh it
should be very good for him but he
messed up this position uh he blundered
the game away but only if kasparov
figures out why he actually put the
bishop on d4 because i'm sure at the
moment he played bishop to d4 he had
this in mind but
uh well it's just a very very very uh
fast game now i think kasparov was in in
in in time trouble for for quite uh
quite a bit of this game
but later on hikaru also got into time
trouble but you know that's besides the
point uh feel free to pause the video
and win this game for kasparov while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
absolute brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
queen captures on a5 i'm just joking
it's not it's a good move but it's not
the one that wins the game even though
uh some of you have thought of this the
problem is after king the b8 and queen
captures on b6 there's just no good
continuation uh of course queen f2 check
is coming and then after king g4 queen
f3 check and you are never getting out
of checking h4 queen h1 check king g4
queen f3 check and so on you can only
lose this game so the move that of
course you guys you guys found after
this pawn to e3 move is uh none other
than bishop captures on b6 and it seems
like such a weird move why would you do
this uh but the point is exactly in this
g6 pawn so here kasparov really had a a
a a
an option or rather
a chance of creating a brilliancy but he
missed it the point is after bishop
captures uh you don't really have a good
move if the king goes here we're gonna
play queen captures on a5 if you go here
just pawn to d7 opens up a discovery so
your only move is to capture the bishop
and once the bishop is captured queen b5
check
all of the squares are covered only
square is king a7 now queen captures an
a5 with check and now again black has
only two options bishop to a6 or you
move the king but regardless of what
black plays your next move will be the
same so let's say you play king to b8
queen to c7 check we would play this
even if bishop to a6 was played because
then it would be uh check to the king on
a7 so now black must trade otherwise he
loses the queen here so queen captures
now pawn captures with check
king captures and now look at this pawn
to g6 that's the point
uh and now of course the thread is g7 g8
uh queen or if f captures then pawn to
f7 and
of course the bishop is not in time as
it's a light square bishop kasparov
would be queening on f8 on a dark square
and the king is too far away so whatever
you play here that doesn't really matter
next move caspar gets a queen and hikaru
resigns so it was in the position but uh
kasparov missed it he played bishop
captures or rather he played queen
captures on e3 uh and now uh he gives
hikaru a chance to start checking so
queen the g2 with check king f4 queen to
h2 with check queen to g3 queen to d2
with check and now kasparov doesn't want
to repeat with queen
d2 he starts running up with the king so
king the e5 and now we have queen to a2
uh now going for
uh
going for and not q6 but controlling
this diagonal not allowing the king to
move and just asking what do you play
here so kasparov goes back uh he if you
push the pawn for example pawn to d7
then okay queen to e6 checking the f4
and the queen to e4 will be checkmate
but uh
kasparov of course goes back
king to f4 we have queen to d5 now going
for queen t for check which would win
the bishop and kasparov just plays king
to e3 incredible blunder in time travel
queen to e3 and the game goes on it's a
draw or even bishop captures on b6 is
still possible but after king to e3 now
kasparov throws the game away queen the
e4 with check and kasparov blunders the
bishop king f2 queen capture sunday for
chuck king f1 and now bishop to e4 and
he was in this position on move 58 that
kasparov resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here you can't
push d7 queen controls that you can't
push g6 the bishop and pawn control that
so there is nothing for you to do you
are down a full piece and there is no
compensation whatsoever
so it was a quite the game caspar played
brilliantly he started very aggressive
with g4 he captured all the all the
critical squares he he really pushed
very very nicely and then at at one
point where hikaru gave him a chance
with this e3 pawn push
he missed the bishop captures on v6 but
it was such a such a beautiful idea uh
this could have been uh kasparov's
fischer random immortal if this had been
played uh just captures capture to trade
off everything because it's forced there
is absolutely nothing black can do to
avoid this we can even show it one more
time because it's so beautiful so after
e3 just bishop captures king captures
queen b5 check king a7 queen captures an
a5 check only moves but it doesn't
matter what the black king does just
trade the queens off captures captures
this comes with checks so you have to
capture back so king captures and g6
spectacular f captures f7 you get a
queen yeah absolutely beautiful so uh uh
shane forecast part of that it it didn't
go through but it was it was a great
game nonetheless by both of them
uh so yeah that's the game uh hope you
guys enjoyed it the first game we'll be
showing from the champion showdown if
you have a favorite of your own do use
hashtag suggestion and i will definitely
look into it i would like to thank abdul
rahman also the simon osborne paul
certainly jose palacio and philippa
palacio yusuf papa in panama for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
this of the champions showdown until it
finishes and also uh i forgot um i i
really wanted to show you something uh
but i forgot to prepare it so if any of
you are still watching i don't know
maybe maybe just left as uh you know you
thought the video was going to finish
but here is an incredible photo by
leonard otis um
from this event of of kasparov and
hikaru
let me just
make that a bit smaller it's absolutely
absolutely beautiful photo
uh there you have it uh absolutely
incredible uh you can see that most of
the players are behind them but they are
they're really focused on something so
if you guys could try to figure out what
they are so focused that i mean it's
like a 2900 player just walked through
the door and they're like oh i i don't
believe it
uh so you know
if you have a a nice idea of what they
might be looking at do do share in the
comment section below
uh so yeah thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day